okay well hello everyone my name is
Richard Albert and I'm really pleased to
have with us today John Barett former
for Minister for Canada among other
things and I'll go over the list of
portfolios he's held but first I just
want to welcome you uh to this first
event of the Year sponsored by the
Canadian studies committee I'm here in
the capacity of the Canadian BenTen
visiting professorship and it's
wonderful to be back here I was a
student here many years ago uh in fact
my advisor my former adviser David
Cameron is here on the Canadian studies
committee and he's been a very strong
supporter of our events this year we
have many planned for you and this is a
great way to start John uh to kick off
our program so thank you very very much
before we start I want to say a few
words of thanks to the people who've
helped make this program possible um
Jesse berety has been been wonderful
thank you uh Omar Aziz uh Rahe Ma chower
Lena Chen Whitney Dole L Haynes George
Joseph Ian Shapiro and Marilyn wils
number of people have helped uh put this
event together and we're very grateful
uh so today of course John Barrett is
here many of you know uh John's past
history let me just go over very briefly
um some of the things that John Barrett
has done over the course of his of his
long career but still very quite young
uh it's remarkable the number of things
that he's accomplished um thus far as
you know he's four foreign former former
uh foreign minister for Canada from 2011
to
2015 before that he held a number of
portfolios uh environment Minister
President of the treasury board Minister
for transport infrastructure and
communities also the leader of the
government in the House of Commons and
before joining um Federal politics he
was of course at Queens Park where he
held a number of portfolios minister of
community and Social Services minister
of energy he was also also government
house leader and now he's a senior
business adviser at Bennett Jones in
Toronto so it's really lovely to have
you here I'll just say one more thing
about John before we begin uh we share
one thing many things in common one of
which is that we're both from Ottawa
area uh John's an Ottawa native uh he's
a golden Gale as well a graduate of
Queens with a ba in political studies we
have a Queens person here it sounds
like a queen's person right here om aiz
I if you're a golden Gale you were a
football player I was not a football
well wonderful uh thank you so much to
all of you for being here and John thank
you for for being here it's great to
have you thank you so let's begin uh I
think the plan is I'll ask a few
questions just to just to begin our
conversation then we'll open it up over
the course of the hour hour and 15
minutes to all of you to raise your
questions and please just introduce
yourselves let us know where you're from
and we'll take it from there but the
first question John is you were a
foreign minister at a very important
time tumultuous time uh in the world
2011 2015 we saw Arab Spring uh
financial
crisis um period of War some movement
toward peace what would you say are some
of the most memorable moments of your
time as foreign minister maybe um some
of your greatest achievements and also
some of your regrets let's start with
most memorable moments um I think you
had the opportunity you every day on the
job to meet some incredible people or
see some people who are going through
some
incredible good and bad times um I can
recall visiting the Zari refugee camp in
Jordan and just be blown away by the
scale of the humanitarian crisis um
walking through a a slum in Mumbai and
seeing the depths of poverty that I had
just never seen before um at the same
time you got to see some of the very
best in people I can recall the day I
met Anoni and just somewhat of a
remarkable human achievement and
accomplishment uh so you saw some of the
very worst in the world with some of the
very best as well and what were some of
the great victories you you helped
Canada get during your time as foreign
minist I think you know my job was to
promote Canadian values and to promote
Canadian interests um there's never
really a Finish Line when you're doing
that uh I think the conclusion of the
transpacific partnership uh discussions
today is a huge uh a huge coup uh for
the country um you know we're a trading
country and the more opportunities we
have to compete on a Level Playing Field
I think the better it'll be for our
economy um you know I think when it
comes to um we had a great initiative
with that the Prime Minister Leed on
child and maternal Health where we've
seen you know literally billions of
dollars of new investment come from uh
the developed economies uh to uh improve
the lives uh and to make a real
difference for young women and their
children um human rights is something
that's very important we really as
Canadians I think probably the biggest
gift lesson that we can part inart on
the world is pluralism you know in
Canada people from all sorts of
different backgrounds different
countries cultures religions can come
together and live in relative peace and
Harmony so whether it was promoting
religious freedoms uh promoting the
rights of women um which has become a
huge priority uh for Canada over the
last number of years and beginning to
finally raise issues about the equality
of sexual minorities uh around the world
and conversations that had never taken
place uh so those are some of the things
are we doing enough uh with the Syrian
refugee crisis in Canada the scale of
this crisis I don't think anyone can
come close to say they're doing enough
um this is a I mean the scale of the
refugee crisis not just from Syria uh
brought from Iraq uh and the region is
incredible and whatever we're doing
we've got to do more um we got to
balance off obviously uh humanitarian
efforts with security efforts um the the
um you know I think where we can
particularly play a role or we have
played a role is helping religious
minorities who are fleeing persecution
and then we look at obviously uh you
know the plight of the most vulnerable
you know women and children um what we
can do there obviously is important I
think certainly when I left government
we were the top in the top five
countries in terms of providing uh you
know committing and providing financial
assistance
to uh to support uh the refugees but
whatever every country is doing we've
obviously got to do a lot more uh I mean
obviously uh you know ending the the
ending the crisis can be the single most
important thing so we don't see more
people forced you know to risk their
lives to
flee one of the things that you
championed as foreign minister are LGBT
rights um how and and why did this
become a foreign policy priority for
Canada under your leadership I think if
you looked at uh you you looked at the
world uh this is a conversation which
just rarely takes place and you know
maybe it's the fact that you know
Gates and lesbians enjoy the same rights
and freedoms in Canada by and large um
that you know because we can take that
in part our experience uh to other
countries around the world but it's just
not acceptable in 2015 for you know new
laws to be uh to be initiated whether
they're in Russia uh whether they're in
Uganda whether they're in Nigeria and
these are issues which had never really
been raised at a lot of international
fores uh and I think Canada uh with uh
the United States particularly under
secretary Clinton uh with the British
government under David Cameron are
finally beginning to start to uh to
raise them and you see the uh you know
horrific uh
persecution uh that sexual minorities
are facing at the hands of of isil in
Syria I just saw on Twitter last night
you know four uh gays were you know
literally throwing off a six-story roof
while a crowd cheered below I mean just
appalling take us inside the foreign
policymaking process so you mentioned
that this had not been something the
Canada was involved in before you became
foreign minister so how do we go from no
conversation to Leading the world how
does that work about leading the world
but first and foremost you got the power
of your country's voice to be able to
speak up whether it's at the general
assembly at the UN um whether it's at uh
the Commonwealth uh whether it's you
know having difficult conversations
bilaterally um these are just
conversations which have never taken
place uh in the past and they just
starting to take place I Canada's been
one of the few countries who's been been
prepared to raise
them let's begin to open up the floor to
questions from the audience I have more
questions but let's let's kick things
off with questions from you
please just introduce
yourself I think what the conservative
government did with LGBT rights
externally was fantastic and very needed
but I'm curious as to how you can
compare that to what happened inside the
country where your party was respons if
your party had been in
power5 Canada would still not have same
sex married right
now I think the mcy decision in Ontario
uh which wasn't appealed by the previous
government wasn't appealed by the
provincial government Ontario it was a
court of appeal decision I think would
have quickly LED you know all 10
provinces and three territories you know
I think uh most politicians have have uh
come the long way on this issue both
prime minister cret and prime minister
Martin voted against gay marriage in I
believe 1999 or 2000 President Obama and
secretary Clinton when they campaigned
for president 08 were against it I think
people's views by and large uh have
evolved and it's just no longer an issue
um
strangely um stepen Harper's commitment
to to reopen the issue probably put the
final Nails in the coffin because after
the V vote in December of 2006 which was
a substantial majority um he was able to
come out to the parliament come out to
the House of Commons and say listen this
is settled we're not reopening it and
that was really the final nail in in the
coffin and it really hasn't been uh
uniss uh in Canadian politics uh since
then and I find it an extraordinary
thing that in the United States the
biggest um opposition to same-sex
marriage is not a not a conservative
politician running for president but an
obscure town a county clerk in Kentucky
uh so it just shows you the Monumental
sea change of of the melting of
opposition and that's a good thing um in
Canada it happened over a period of 20
years um whether it was you know the
Human Rights Code in the 80s whether it
was uh the m versus H decision in
Ontario in 99 or whether it was uh with
the the McMurry decision and you know
Roy McMurry was a former conservative
attorney general uh in Ontario for 10
years before uh before uh you know
before he served on the on the bench but
it's just it's funny in Canada this is
just no longer an issue seems like in
2005 when or when you guys were
campaigning that it was used to appeal
to the basis instincts of your base and
yeah I think and it didn't work I don't
think uh a lot of parties can be proud
of their record in the past um I can
remember on the issue of samesex belal
benefits um you know some of the most
hateful and mean-spirited speeches were
by new Democratic MPP sitting in Bob
Ray's
caucus the Liberal Party had promised
you know to supported and then didn't U
so I don't think there's I don't I think
all three parties can't be particularly
proud of their record uh the good news
is I think it's largely settled um and
it's just not something that that it it
literally it literally disappeared uh
from uh in the course of about five
years um and I think in the United
States I think new KR you said this is
just like an iceberg that's melting in
the hot summer sun and uh the fact that
uh President Obama uh when he you know
did 180° change in his position you know
6 months before his an election and it
really was a significant issue in that
election is was pretty
telling I think what we we we as well
can do is I mean we're talking uh I mean
the debates we have in Canada about
marriage or spousal benefits are nothing
when you talk about the criminalization
and the death penalty that we see in
parts of the world um and there's you
know there are many countries with laws
on the books that have been enforced for
years but when you see countries like in
Nigeria or Uganda bringing in new laws
uh you know in the in the 21st century
that's just not acceptable and uh you
know this is starting to come up um the
United States has uh the United States
has done a lot um particularly when
Hillary started out and the British
government uh is doing a lot
too John let's move to TPP which you
mentioned just a moment ago what are the
implications of the TPP on the Canadian
election which is ongoing right now well
see um uh this is a huge consequential
you know Trade Agreement um uh it it
rewrites NAFTA so it's a modernization
of the uh us and Mexican relationship in
terms of trade you know we already have
trade agreements with you know Peru and
Chile uh but it also gives us trade
agreements with Vietnam with brunai with
Singapore with Australia New Zealand
most importantly though with Japan the
world's third largest economy I think
this tries to in the absence of success
in the Doha round this um uh this sets
the pace uh for what the framework of a
global deal uh either will be or will
evolve to uh particularly in a part of
the world and the age Pacific region
which uh which I think needs it uh so I
think it's positive I it's a good thing
I think uh the Democrats have
traditionally not been supportive of
trade deals um uh you know liberals have
been you know less enthusiastic about
them so I think it'll it'll say it'll uh
it'll be an interesting uh you know day
and two weeks and then with the next
when the next Parliament reconvenes
whatever happens um we'll see let me ask
you a question that I think uh many of
the people in the room are are wondering
or have wondered which is why did you
decide to resign when you did here you
are at the height of your career as a
political actor in Canada at the height
of your power and influence and you
decide to step away I think it's nice to
go uh when you're on top of your game I
spent 10 years in ontaro politics 10
years in federal politics I had 10
different cabinet jobs uh I had a great
run uh just decided that it was uh that
I wouldn't seek a seventh term and I
think sometimes uh
um sometimes uh people stay too long in
jobs and I mean there's a few other
people who have had 10 cabinet posts I
had a great run and I thought Foreign
Affairs was a great way to cap off a
career and to do other things I think
that's good we might see you again I
don't know what that it's the only
business where you leave you retire and
people immediately wonder when you're
coming back
questions yes omir yeah um thanks for
coming so I have a two-part question
actually two questions one less
contentious one more contentious I'll
start with the less contentious one
first then I'll cut you off and we go to
the next question yeah um so I believe
when you were foreign minister it was
when you were foreign minister Canada
closed our Embassy in in Iran and that
seemed to have been um I'm actually not
sure what motivated I believe it was in
September or October of
2012 um so what motivated that decision
especially considering that 3 years
later now the world powers led by the
United States and even with Russia and
China signed on have signed a nuclear
agreement with uh with Iran so that's
the first question the second question
is um we've seen in the domestic
political scene the ncab has become an
issue um in the Canadian election now
I'm not someone who thinks that this is
something people should wear but I
recognize that in a free Society women
should be left the choice should be left
to the individual to decide whether they
should wear that or not and you know
your former boss prime minister Harper
has made it a point to tout you know his
anti- neov position and to appeal um the
federal court decision to the Supreme
Court one woman's decision to wear a
ncob during a ceremony even though she
agreed that she would turn her face and
take that with the citizenship if there
was a woman there and reveal her face
and I wanted to get your comment on that
considering that you've been a defender
of religious minorities elsewhere around
the world and I think that we need to
stay consistent and be supporting
religious minorities in our own country
as well sure I I um I believe people are
free to make their own decisions to wear
in a cab or not uh that's an individual
Freedom people should be entitled to um
I guess it speaks to the kind of Canada
that we want for the future um and I
think there's a real and significant
concern about the subjugation of women
um and you know uh I was minister of
Transport we had to deal with this issue
where we have um you know both at the uh
at the uh air report screening and at
the gate would we have to have a private
room for people to be able to show their
face would we have to have ensure that
we had uh a woman and a man on duty at
all times to be able to deal with that
and I think it's when you're you know
there's some instances you know taking
the oath or when you're boarding an
airline when you're getting a picture
taken for your driver's license where
you'll be required uh to uh you know to
uh to show your faith um to validate
your identity and uh you know beyond
that people are free to do uh you know
what they want in a free an open Society
um with respect to Iran
um the the biggest issue was um the
security the Safety and Security of our
men and women of Canadian embassy that
was not a secure Embassy there was no
setback from the street so the the
diplomats that decried what we had done
I don't know where they were over the
last 20 years ensuring we had a safe
Embassy for our folks we watched closely
what happened with the British when
their Embassy was
stormed um Parliament had passed
legislation requiring me as Minister of
Foreign Affairs to designate State
sponsors of Terror and the deadline was
the end of September 2012 and I felt
very uncomfortable U designate Iran as
state sponsor of Terror and then leaving
our staff vulnerable uh in in the center
of Tran so we made the difficult
decision to uh to close it we hadn't had
an ambassador there for many years the
relationship was dealing with very
lowlevel officials um and frankly not
much we had accomplished much since the
death of uh uh zarak kmy the
photojournalist uh and then um you know
the cover up of uh of the details of
that so you know um we made a difficult
decision and I stand by it it was the
right thing to to do um Iran is the
biggest spons state sponsor of Terror in
the world uh you know they've got the
blood on their hands for literally
thousands well they got the blood on
their hands of in the deaths of
thousands of people in Syria um they uh
you know support directly the government
supporting uh you groups like Hamas uh
has baa and others U their abysmal and
deteriorating human rights record under
roohani more people put to death since
Rohani came into Power um and then of
course their nuclear program um I I mean
one of the cornerstones of Canan foreign
policy is um you know nuclear
nonproliferation and I fear were not
withstanding the agreement I fear were
on the uh on uh on the wrong path and
the one thing I can say with the
exception of uh uh the government of
Assad Canada's views on Iran
are the exact same as every other
country in the region in the Middle East
whether it's Israel whether it's the
Emirates whether it's Saudi Arabia
whether it's Jordan uh there's real
concerns
there John let me ask you a question
about Canada standing in the world how
would you say Canada standing in the
world today compares to where it was in
the past has there been a decline is it
better in your view where are we today I
think different governments have
different philosophies and how they
conduct uh policies I think by and large
the Canan foreign policy is is you know
there has been a radical shift um you
know I think if there were people who
preferred the previous government's
foreign policy you know their friends
around the world would not agree with
our foreign policy nor would you know
they agree with our Economic Policy nor
would they uh agree with other policies
we've taken I I think by and large uh
around the world Canada enjoys um you
good relations if you look at uh the PO
Pol the public opinion polling that Jim
zogby does he's a big American pollster
he's head of the American Arab Institute
uh he's done public opinion polling in
just about every Arab country and Canada
is consistently at or near the top in
terms of people's perceptions of us I
think as far as Canada's influence in
the world I think we have a a much a
world with is much more decentralized
you know it's not all about the G7 it's
the G20 uh it's not all about you know
the power of you know the United States
in the west versus uh the Communist
world uh you have a lot of emerging I
mean China has a lot more power than it
had years ago countries like Mexico have
a lot more power uh countries like
Indonesia have a lot more power um so
you've seen the power is just much more
diffuse and uh I think you know we with
35 million people uh we punch above our
weight but in a world of 7 billion we
have so much more power India I can
speak about Korea I can speak about
South Africa Nigeria um so power is much
more uh diffused but I think you know I
put a lot of time for example a lot of
the world world's hotspots uh in are in
the Middle East and we have we have a
fantastic relationship with just about
every Arab country um we first time ever
Rel uh We've have a representative to
the organization of Islamic cooperation
we have good relations in the Gulf good
relations in North Africa um whether you
go to Cairo Riyad uh or Abu Dhabi Arman
it's uh it's pretty good in the Asian
countries put a huge new focus in
Southeast Asia not just in China and
India but in the Asian countries where
it's very
positive um in South America we've done
a
lot yes please hi name Michael I'm an
undergrad from Toronto um Canada has an
incredibly diverse and very large
immigrant population uh and this means
there's a lot of personal contact
between Canadians uh and family members
living abroad I'm wondering if you could
speak a little bit to the opportunities
and complications that this presents
when executing foreign policy policy um
it's it's it's an opportunity obviously
on issues like trade uh and relations
that uh I think that no government has
able to been able to fully exploit which
I think is uh uh I think is a bad thing
we got to do you know a better job of
harnessing that um you know I think that
you have you will have certain immigrant
communities with very strong views for
against uh um various regimes at home um
you know whether it's uh um you look at
the uh the uh population the immigrants
we've had from Sri Lanka obviously tamel
have Canadian tamils have you know are
politically active and have strong views
um if you look at um The Immigrant
communities from China you know some are
from Taiwan some are from Hong Kong some
are pro regime some are sympathetic to
the Fallen gong it's it's it's all over
the map I think the end of the day we
should take decisions which are you know
principal decisions in the best interest
of the country obviously you know it is
informed by experiences that uh that uh
that as a country as a whole that we uh
that we have um I think um you know um
my part is the only center right party
that I can think of in the world who
wins The Immigrant vote um so we're
doing something different than a lot of
other parties who are Center left you go
into some conservative party events and
there are no white angle Saxon people uh
in some communities and I'll tell you
that was incredibly different than it
was 30 years ago when I first got
involved in politics or if you had a
vowel at the end of your name uh you
know that was uh that was you know rare
um but we have uh we have new immigrant
communities that are incredibly
politically active uh I mean you look at
the number of South Asian members
problem we have in all parties it's huge
significant um that's one you know one
example I think that's a good thing that
uh you know that uh the parliament
increasing looks like the new face uh of
Canada by and large that's a welcoming
thing I think the single biggest
example we can set is the is the
pluralism uh that Canada has built up um
which is uh a great example for the rest
of the world too often um you see
particularly religious cleavages uh be
huge destabilizing effects uh in other
in in other parts of the world you know
when you look at the Coptic Christians
in Egypt when you look at um uh you look
at uh Christians in uh in uh uh uh Iraq
which have been you know dwindling if
you look at the persecution of amadia
Muslims in Iran you look at uh uh it's
uh I mean just there's all kinds of
examples we set up an office of
religious freedom uh which is really
seeking to to promote you know
pluralism um around the world and done a
lot of work with uh His Highness the
Ager Khan um we certainly need a uh we
need to do to do more with you know
like-minded folks
my name
is Toronto just on this question of
pluralism one of the big critiques of
the Harvard government is they've done
more to differentiate between citizens
than any other government uh in can
history um thinking a examples one is
this new move to try to restrict uh
canans abroad from voting the second
being ushering of bill c24 which
actually relocates The Authority for
revoking citizenship from um the courts
to a partisan elected official the
minister of immigration and the third
being sort of this um part and parel of
the what people have called Rising
anti-immigrant sentiment you look at
stepen haror in the debates
differentiating between Old Stock
Canadians and immigrant Canadians so I
want to know sort of broadly what you
make of that critique uh what do you
agree I I I don't know what what was in
the prime minister's heart when he
talked about Old Stock Canadians but um
I can tell this is our government is a
very very pro-immigration government we
brought in more immigrants than any
government in Canadian history um we've
resettled you know more refugees per
capita than any other country in the
world and we're doing more not less than
we did before I think the fact that we
win the Immigrant vote um you know
speaks volumes um you know uh the
candidate running to replace me in
Parliament is someone who came to this
country at age 13 he served as a police
officer for 12 years worked at the RCMP
for two uh you know he's a black Somali
Muslim Canadian and you know I endorsed
him for the nomination he's got great
support in our party um so I guess I
just don't share uh you know I just
don't share that that conclusion you
know um we revoke people's citizenship
um if they're war
criminals um so people have dual
nationality it's not something I have a
problem with um with respect to um
what was the the other issu oh the
voting um you know listen I just if if
you don't live in Canada you don't pay
taxes in Canada um I just don't have a
problem with people not being able to uh
to vote if you're a Canadian citizen
you're not in and you live abroad you're
not entitled to healthcare you're not
entitled to uh you know uh to you
receive social programs and so if um
there's a Canadian who's never set foot
in Canada um I just think them having
the ability to set taxation rates and
set the laws with which we all live on
under is is just not the uh is just not
the appropriate way to go you others can
fairly disagree uh that's a reasonable
difference of opinion those That's My
Views I suspect it's probably
overwhelming the overwhelming view in uh
in
Canada whom do you admire
John either in politics or out of
politics I have a lot this is this will
surprise people I have a lot of regard
for Hillary Clint Clinton she's smart
she's tough uh uh the aaon is someone
who I have huge regard for incredible
guy um you know strangely his views
are very Canadian esque in terms of uh
pluralism he has uh We've supported the
Center International Center for
pluralism in Ottawa uh he's got the new
his new Museum and art gallery in
Toronto which is fantastic
um I've just had the chance to work with
some really amazing people and you can
see the you know the very best in the
human spirit and you can see also the
very worst you know someone like Putin
you know the very worst someone who's
just evil um you know uh I mean the
people say we have a frozen conflict in
Ukraine well it's not a frozen conflict
we have people die every day uh we see
him now um indiscriminately targeting
areas uh where Isis has never been
present in uh in Syria I mean he's given
material and moral support that is
allowed Assad to uh you know to to to
carry on and that's resulted in the
biggest humanitarian crisis and given
birth to
Isis yes juliia talk
about uh Isis or S material
support and how horrendous and evil he
is Putin is but your government wasn't
afraid to make A1 15 billion arms deal
with Saudi Arabia who have horrendous
human rights issues in their country
including right now I think he was 17y
old when he was arrested at a protest
and he is going to be
crucified sure that's an ni supported
that deal uh I was there uh when it was
signed I signed off on it personally uh
I support it I don't want to see um the
Islamic State uh who wants to create a
caliphate to be able to march into Saudi
Arabia to try to take Mecca and Medina I
think it's in our our interests that uh
the kingdom uh can uh you know maintain
its borders I think we also have uh in
that region Iran uh which is materially
trying to intervene in just about every
single country in the region and I don't
think that it's uh it's in anyone's
interest that they expand their uh
sphere of influence into uh into Saudi
Arabia um I feel really strongly about
that um that has been said this school
create a lot of jobs in Canada um it
doesn't mean though
that we it's always a choice between our
values and our interests um I can tell
you I spent 45 minutes with now King
Salmon last fall and had a long
conversation with him about human rights
uh I visited the um the uh Human Rights
Commission in Riad um a long discussions
with respect to what um Saudi Arabia
should do particularly about with the
equality of men and women in their
society and and I think we you can use
the relationship we have to uh to uh you
know to raise these issues which we
do um you know obviously we don't share
uh a lot of the values that they do in
Saudi Arabia um but I think we're better
to engage than uh than not
engage what guarantees do you have that
they're not going to use those against
their own people um light armored
vehicles I mean I haven't I haven't seen
you know them have to use much military
power I just think we'd want to see them
their borders por us and wide open to
Isis uh or to uh or to you know Iran's I
mean Iran is now uh has troops in Iraq
uh has troops in Syria they're directly
arming the houthis they're occupying one
or two islands that belong to the
Emirates um I don't think it's in our
interest that they'd be able to expand
their uh their influence uh any further
um uh you know we're at War right now
and Saudi Arabia's uh also has done air
missions in Syria um you uh you know you
have to find the world as you you have
to take the world as you find it not as
you wish it would be you we worked with
uh with some pretty nefarious characters
uh in other times of our history which I
don't think her is bad uh but listen uh
it's not in either world we can do both
but I I I should say that I strongly
support the deal um and I and I tell
I'll tell you this we didn't get any
questions in Parliament when when we
brought it
through you know those those Auto
Workers are represented by UNIF for
Union and you know the NDP didn't get up
and ask a single question in Parliament
so you know um I think there was uh a
consensus that was the right thing to do
I see now we're in an election campaign
and you know people uh voices were a
little bit louder but they were far more
timid uh when the deal was first
signed but I I can I'll say this listen
I can Regional people can differ that's
my opinion um reasonable people can uh
can differ and you try to to tackle the
issues as best you can um it uh it
rarely though you find one that's you
can hit both the values and the
interests at the same time but I want to
tell you though we do have strong uh we
do have good discussions on human rights
as people would expect us to have at the
at the most senior levels um what I
believe particularly in that part of the
world if we can do one single thing it's
the role that women play in that type of
society uh whether it's women in peace
and security whether it's women being
involved in government and Civil Society
the more women uh that are involved the
better that Society is going to be you
look at the United Arab Emirates which
is not a liberal democracy you know you
know woman Ambassador at the U they have
a woman Commerce Minister and you look
at the freedom index that exists in the
emirats it's a great example for the
rest of the uh uh rest of the
region what is the state of the Canada
US relationship and here I guess I want
to ask about Keystone and whether that
tells us anything about where the
relationship is I think the relationship
by and large is good um Keystone has
obviously been a problem um you know
listen we've had problems I mean the
previous government had a big issue with
softwood Lumber um uh you know prime
minister Maron uh had big fights with
Reagan on South Africa and on sanctions
with apartheid we had big issues on Aid
rain until we finally resolve them near
the end of President Reagan's time in
office um so Keystone is bad uh you know
strongly supported I think the Americans
should uh but that shouldn't be the the
whole relationship I mean obviously um
you know we have been you know when the
president you know things like the trust
fund for Afghanistan when he called
Canada was there uh the fight against
the Islamic State you we're the only
Western Country bombing in Syria as well
as uh in Iraq uh we're doing training on
the ground with the kurd um so I think
you we're a reliable friend and Ally of
the United States um I just take
exceptional issue with their uh the time
and the the delays on Keystone um I'll
try to find a way to to uh to forgive
Hillary for her position in Canada of
course we never take strong political
decisions during an election campaign
for political reasons we would never do
that in
person om yes do you want
to yeah I actually want to follow up on
the Saudi Arabia question because you
mentioned Isis and you mentioned Iran
and um look no one's going to defend
Iran's human rights records record
because it's indefensible but I I like I
I just I hear irony in in your statement
when you talk about Isis because Isis
and Saudi Arabia are exactly part of the
same coin in fact they're on the same
side of the same coin their ideology is
exactly the same in terms of the
punishments that they give to people in
terms of the degrading treatment of
human beings especially women in terms
of the treatment of religious minorities
they're bombing Yemen right now where 30
people are dying every single day there
have been 5,000 people have died already
80% of that country is malnourished um
they've beheaded over a 100 people this
year they're going to set a record for
beheadings and crucifixions this year
they're the exact same as Isis and so I
share your human rights concerns
criticisms but I just I I'm sorry I hear
hypocrisy when I say that when you say
that you defend a deal we're selling
these guys $1 15 billion it would be
like selling Isis 15 billion I just
don't share that view um I just don't
share that view s i you look at the uh
at the effort in Yemen you clearly have
uh uh you know Iran trying to expand its
fear of
influence
um and I I can understand why they're
not prepared to to to sit back and allow
that to happen uh Iranian expansionist
uh motives and wanting to have you know
Pol political hedony in the region is I
think just bad for uh for everyone you
know I don't support the uh the death
penalty I think is wrong uh particularly
the way it's carried out in uh in the
Kingdom um and we can have that
conversation I don't I don't think
though I just I just don't accept the
notion that Sai Arabia and an Isis are
synonymous I just I just don't you don't
find a little bit problematic that we we
sold this regime $5 billion and I signed
off on the deal and supported it yeah uh
and not one single member of parliament
not one NDP member Parliament got up and
complained about it not one liberal
Member of Parliament stood up and asked
me a tough question about it uh so I
guess you could say their science their
silence was acceptance listen there's
many issues which are uh are problematic
there we have we have good conversations
uh with them um but I think you know we
got to be clear we don't want uh we
don't want uh I Isis isil's desire to
establish a caliphate I mean they would
have to take me and Medina to realize
that Vision I think it would be a
disaster for the entire planet if they
did it and uh you know we'll play a
small commercial role domestic political
and economic interest then that
motivated it cuz it clearly wasn't but I
clearly I clearly outl lighted my views
on on the foreign policy amplifications
of it which which I led with but you L I
appreciate um uh I apprey sure Regional
people can disagree um there wasn't they
should elect a member of parliament who
would ask a question which they didn't
yeah I mean the liberal NP moral
hypocrisy doesn't excuse conservative
moral hypocracy I uh I'm just saying is
I'm just saying is you have to make
difficult decisions uh you can't pick
and choose the uh uh the ones you have
to confront uh but I signed it and I
support it I'm you know quite
quite comfortable defending them yeah I
guess I just expected more for a party
that claims to defend human rights
because this is one of the worst human
rights abusers in the world second
probably North Korea uh why I don't I
wouldn't agree with that but well we'll
come back to object we'll come back to
the region because I want to ask you
about Israel but first I want to ask you
John to go back to when you were the age
of many of the students here uh in the
room uh probably minister at that
age let's say between uh 1923 or there
abouts because you got into politics at
25 26 um what were you thinking at that
time that you wanted to do with your
with your life I always wanted to be a
member of provincial Parliament and a
provincial Minister those are the only
two really political goals that I had um
I happened to meet Step Harper when I
was a teenager and uh helped him out in
2003 2004 when he was running for the
Leisure of the party and when he lost an
election I expect him to win I thought
some people have to get off the bench
and end the game to uh to see us
establish first a credible opposition
which I think every democracy should
have um and then obviously an
alternative government mhm
mhm and so you reached both of those
goals um at a very young age by 31 is
that right you had been elected to the
provincial Parliament and been a cabinet
minister I think when I got to Ottawa I
just didn't have anything to prove
because I felt just comfortable with my
skin um and when you're you in politics
I think you regret things you don't do
rather than things you you did and when
you had a when I had a chance we left
government in uh
2003 and I predicted we'd probably be
out for eight years and then when you
could get back into government in two
years it was just such an incredible
opportunity to try to make a difference
I think you were probably more
comfortable making decisions more
comfortable tackling problems uh more
comfortable with
risk yes please I wanted to ask a little
bit about um something that came up when
you were talking about the Keystone
Pipeline in terms of Canada's role in
environmental movements around the world
that you probably touched on in foreign
affairs and in your time in the
environment what are your kind of
thoughts on Canada's role as um tackling
issues like climate change I think I
think more than anything is we need a
comprehensive agreement uh from all
large emitters uh for real reductions I
think
regardless um it just
doesn't you know if someone's putting a
fire hose in the bathtub it just doesn't
really make much sense to be bailing
out and when we have countries like
China who won't even agree to a common
reporting standard not alone a common
verification standard it's just very
problematic and if we're just
exporting um uh exporting our emissions
to foreign countries uh we won't be
accomplishing anything and I think we
should almost take a hypocritic oath at
first do no damage to the environment I
use an example you know British Columbia
has a carbon tax which seems very
Progressive and and heralded by a lot of
environmentalists well you just simply
don't buy your cement fabricate cement
in British Columbia you just buy it from
China where the clinker process is uh
more carbon intensive and then you have
all the emissions from the transport of
it so let's get all the big emitters uh
on board and then I think real action
can uh can happen I think we continue
just have the same conversation over and
over and over again and uh we never seem
to get a deal that will deliver that but
we've seen China in the US making some
some progress where where's Canada what
progress have they made well at least
there's discuss about having some sort
of agreement you know I I I agree that
you know the progress has been not as
much as we would have like to see but
have they gone forward one inch I would
think so more than but in but in but in
China which is now the world's largest
emitter they haven't committed to reduce
their carbon emissions by a single ton
for 15 years they haven't committed to
even stop growing their carbon emissions
for the next 15 years I have a lot of
friends in China I admire the Chinese
they haven't even agreed on the same
reporting standard between Annex one and
anex 2 countries so I mean great um
great photo op and great announcement of
it but I asked u a senior American
friend in the Obama Administration with
this Canada China deal will emissions be
higher among the world's two largest
emission in 15 years or will they be
lower and they couldn't answer so I
think science is tremendously important
in this discussion but I think
mathematics is just as important and
whatever we commit to doing let's have a
clear let's have the the clear math and
to present it uh I'll give you an
example uh the provincial government
Ontario has closed five Coal Fire
generating stations I oppose that at the
time I said you couldn't do it by 2007
when they promised an all party
legislative committee came forward said
you could do it by
2015 they did they I think they closed
the last one in 2013 or
2014 uh but there you have real
reductions in carbon you can actually
measure it it's not like being sold to
offset credit somewhere else it's less
carbon in um in the uh uh in the planet
we need more efforts that are going to
be real and tangible and less that's a
shell game and we really haven't
accomplished anything if we close our
five Coal Fire generating stations and
then they open up five in a year in uh
in China and we got to remember this is
a global problem some people will make
the case let's lead well in Ontario our
electricity prices have gone through the
roof we're importing electricity from
the United States where there's you know
two Detroit Edison plants and South
across the the bridge in Southwestern
Naro which pump out a lot of uh a lot of
emissions so let's let's just my my view
is is let's get all the big players no
one's expecting like U you know an
Ethiopia or Jamaica to come to the table
but you know any country who's got you
know $ 1.75 trillion dollar of foreign
currency reserves I think could
certainly agree the common reporting
standard and I feel really strongly
about uh about that um
uh I do
fear uh the politics of this I mean I I
read an exchange between um David Suzuki
and Justin Trudeau well where Trudeau
called him a sanctimonious ass and David
Suzuki called him a
TP I agre welcome to my hell uh you know
um you know I'd like to see us take real
action but meaningful action that's
consequential yes please um I sorry
Emily um I did my I'm not Canadian but I
did my underr in Montreal um so I like
Canadian politics things um I feel like
if I simplify and maybe you'll be
opposed to my simplification but if I
simplify your last argument a bit it
would sound like if we don't get all the
world players on board with the
environmental um challenges that we're
facing then there's no point in doing
anything at home and I feel like when we
when you when you look at the our sense
it's a very local environmental issue so
isn't there a point in doing something
at home even though we can't get
everybody on board um I mean listen the
goal is to reduce emissions if we take
actions to reduce emissions and people
who we do trade with China's our second
largest trading partner increases
emission we won't have accomplished uh
the objective so let's let's look at
mathematics and ensure that if we're
going to take action it's going to cost
us economically uh that uh that we get a
benefit uh from it what do you make of
the taron's impact on Canada's
environment specifically I mean you know
we've gotten rid of the previous
government brought in big tax subsidies
for them The Accelerated Capital cost
deduction we got rid of it um I'm one
who strongly believes in new
technologies um the previous government
in Alberta uh put in a carbon Levy
there's a tech fund sitting there with a
lot of money in it which hasn't been
deployed uh which should be I don't
think the oil companies are actually
getting the squeeze to to deploy that
technology to the extent that they uh
that they should um let's give the new
government in Alberta an opportunity one
thing I don't support is transferring
wealth you know from Alberta to other
provinces if if there's money paid into
a tech Fund in Alberta let's let it be
deployed at Alberta uh you know with uh
the oil sands or whether it's uh the
chemical industry I support regulating
large final emitters but what I don't
want to do is to Simply say you know
what we did in British Columbia is you
know put a carbon tax on cement and then
just import it from China because you'll
make se you know cement more expensive
and uh the environment will get worse
not better so that's uh that's my view I
use the example if you had a big rowboat
if someone put a fire hose to fill it up
with water you know I'm going to stop
bailing uh because it won't have uh not
just much effect it you're still going
to be going down and we continue to have
this debate and I tell you the speech
that I gave at the Bali uh Summit of the
United Nations framework convention on
climate change was quite controversial
the EU is that's their policy
today um that is you know Antonio um the
baroso the former president of the
European Union U before he left gave a
speech that was virtually word for word
what I said back in 2007 and um you know
we've just got to tackle that to get the
big the big players participating uh or
we just we'll take significant action
there'll be significant costs and
they'll be not just no effect but it'll
actually get worse um others have a
different view um it's uh it's uh a very
challenging
file yes um so we talked a little bit
about uh Syria in our in our discussion
I know going to take a look at another
issue later on on on sort of the Israel
side of of um the Middle East situation
but I I just wanted to ask one one
further question just given the the
change and the evolution the Syria
situation in the last week with Russian
intervention um I was just wondering if
we if maybe your thoughts on on what we
should be doing with an older policy in
the Syrian situation which is sort of
the Kurds and our support for the Kurds
military and political and whether the
government should be doing more but
especially in light of sort of
escalating tensions in Turkey political
tensions in Turkey involving the Kurds
and now the the Russian situation in in
Syria I think the Kurds have been great
friends to Canada we're doing a training
mission in their bill um cuz I I think
we're comfortable uh with training uh
the Kurds uh I know the US has done
training with some of the more
reasonable elements in Syria that has
been less effective um
um in some respects where we're seeing
is there was no pluralism in the
government in their bill in uh Baghdad
and you saw the country begin to
fragment uh between sunisha and Kurdish
and um that's a problem we've gone from
in Syria worrying about with the
opposition um respect pluralism to you
know would they slaughter minorities
if of moved away from the West in
domestic political situation and
has not necessarily aligned itself with
the views of other NATO
allies especially now with the kurish
situation yeah but I obviously uh the
government of anchor has taken a
different stand that was the vision atat
Turk um you know I like the idea of NATO
or NATO member countries working with
regional Partners uh you look at the
United Arab Emirates in my adult
lifetime I think we've taken kinetic
action six times and all six times we've
done it with the amadis U I think that's
a good thing I think jordanians are good
partners in the fight against ISO for
example um so uh I think it's important
I think we saw in Afghanistan is there
was a lot of NATO countries who were
prepared to be active in Afghanistan but
you know they just didn't want their
soldiers to leave base and they put a
lot of covenants on their participation
and that was a disappointment I think
not just uh uh not just to the United
States but to the the future of the
alliance I think we look at um we look
at Russia's incursion into um in Crimea
and then eastern
Ukraine um you know there's a wide
variety of views in in NATO and I mean
Ukraine is not a a NATO member country
but I we've got to stand firm it's just
not acceptable for one country to try to
you redraw the borders of Europe through
unilateral military action in the 21st
century and I think if anything can
relationship with NATO is probably
growing stronger and our relationship
with Eastern Europe has growing
stronger yes please hi I'm
jine
human specifically
recission
issues to enter into inquiry
on
listen
just
conach sure listen um I'll take uh you
know I'll I'll uh invite anyone in the
Free World to come and look at uh the
human rights that Canadians enjoy and
and uh in the history of human
civilization I don't I think there's
precious few places in the world uh
where human rights are so widely
respected and practice and in principle
um with the issue of indigenous women um
we just there's a there's I think this
is more an elite-based policy discussion
and a more practical one I just think
spending $50 million on a royal
commission or an inquiry uh where a lot
of lawyers would get rich simply it's
just not an effective way to tackle the
problem I think there is a lot of
violence uh in Aboriginal communities
that's a problem I think when Aboriginal
women go missing in urban areas I think
let's be frank if these were
six-year-old blond-haired children from
upper middle class families uh they
would get a lot more attention because
we don't value we have our society
hasn't given value to every life and I
think we need to uh and that's not a
code word for pro-life because I'm pro-
Choice um but it's that that's there are
concrete measures we've got to take
there's still a tremendous amount of
racism and some some parts of the
country I went into a Northern British
Columbia to a Tim Horton's coffee shop
and it astounded me because I grew up in
Ottawa and I've just never seen this all
the aboriginals were in one side of the
the coffee shop and uh all of the uh
Caucasians were in the other I just
astounded me because I had never seen
anything uh like that in in Canada so I
think there's uh there's got to be just
more uh more we can do to tackle the
Aboriginal questions of Canada have uh
have been a challenge for our government
just as they were with the previous
governments um there's no easy uh
there's no easy
solutions thought I a hand up here
yes certainly Folks at NATO like to tell
us that um we only spend about
.9% uh uh our GDP on Military where the
NATO were supposed to be for 2% I'd like
to see us spend more um having said that
um I'm just about all of these missions
we're prepared to do the heavy lifting
where no one else will you know we took
after the United Kingdom and and Britain
Kingdom the United States we took more
casualties per capita than other other
country in the world in Afghanistan
after 911 you know um came to the
campaign in Libya Med canadi lead it we
were the only
not to put up a red card every morning
saying we would bomb here or not bomb
there so we're prepared to do our share
of the of the heavy lifting when it's
required um obviously we can do more
it's the question of money there only so
there's only so much uh money you've got
uh and a lot of competing uh uh a lot of
competing interests um Healthcare and
education obviously the number one
priority of the average Canadian and
that's where our money that's where the
taxpayers money
goes at a huge and we've increased since
stepen Harper became prime minister the
healthc care budget Federal transfers
have gone up by 6% every single year
postsecondary education by 3% every
single year um and that's a you know I
it's number two priorities of canans but
uh number one number two priorities of
Canadians but you know at some point
there's going to be a taxation
department and a health department in
this in our country and that's
unsustainable uh Healthcare is really
important but so too is the environment
so to is uh policing so to is uh uh you
know one of the jobs I have now is
advisor to the on ter Association for
Community Living people don't think of
helping people with an intellectual
disability is a big priority when you
ask public opinion pollsters um other
people with with with voices which
aren't as loud and we need to keep their
interest in mind as
well I wanted to ask about um
transparency in government because this
has been a recurring critique of the
Harper government that since it's been
come into power in 2006 that there's
been sort of a clamp down an increase in
secrecy so that individual ciens
don't have the access to information
that they need especially in the digital
age when things should be more
transparent so I'm thinking about things
like the elimination of the National
Science advisor I'm thinking about the
muzzling of environment Canada
scientists where we've seen press
reports about climate change go down 80%
I'm talking about things like the fair
election act where the chief electoral
officer was told that he could not even
promote the act of voting you would
think that in 2015 you would want more
people to come out to the polls
considering that we've had historic lows
um the elimination of the long form
census again was criticized by left and
by right members on the right and I I
have to ask that what motivates this I
mean apart from the result that we know
that people are going to have less
information and they're going to be
voting or not voting based on less
information which might favor one party
over the other but you would think that
a government that came into Power based
on liberal corruption in 2006 would be
more committed to transparency and open
government and yet we've seen Trends
completely in the opposite short a bunch
of Alles or two of them we one we just
didn't think threatening put people in
jail if they didn't fill up their long
form census was a bit extreme in in the
21st century I'll use the other example
about um elections Canada uh
deciding U where to promote
voting I had a group come into my
constituency office and they said don't
we want to see the highest percentage of
Canadians come out and vote I said
absolutely and I said what do you think
about uh elections Canada targeting
University campuses to get young people
out to vote for the first time oh that
would be a great thing Mr bear great
they're going to put special uh polling
stations on University campuses to get
young people lot of great Mr be well
great what if I had someone come in from
the local Catholic women's league saying
let's put voting boosts at churches on
Sunday mornings and then we can get more
Christian evangelicals and Roman
Catholics out to vote wouldn't that be
great well I don't think I like that Mr
be so I just think when you have uh
elections candid decide which
demographic they're going to promote to
get out and vote it can be hugely
consequential to uh to election
and it shouldn't be um you know it
shouldn't be a government bureaucrat
making making that decision it shouldn't
it be a government bureaucrat making
that decision rather than what sort of
values are they going to come into play
in terms of how they use that power you
know use the example we have there's a
church near my home there's 3,000 people
that go there every Sunday we hold a
special Advance poll there we get you
would probably get an extra 500 people
out to vote I can tell you I'm for gay
marriage and I'm pro-choice I'm not sure
I want them doing that
yeah it seems as though if election
candada wanted to Target certain but but
I'm saying what I'm saying is that that
gives the their values would come into
play making those type of decisions and
I have a real problem with that you tget
universities because there's disperate
populations there from all over the
place and they
don't that's not I'm just I'm just
saying is that you could say you could
go to a you could go to a large
Evangelical Church and you get more
people to vote but that's got nothing to
do with what I
said I'm saying I'm saying as I don't
like I don't like a government
bureaucrat making those type of uh
decisions you can agree people can agree
or uh just just well that's you know
people can disagree do you have a number
on how many people went to jail because
they didn't fill out their law senses I
just think threatening I didn't say put
them in jail he said threatening to put
them so I I I'm almost certain about
this and maybe someone people L we were
minority government when that happened
we survived another two and a half years
after so it couldn't have been that bad
because the government enjoyed the
confidence of the house and the
opposition for another two years let me
ask a question want to I'm I'm
interested in details um and I'd love to
know about a day in the life of a
foreign minister so are you checking
your blackberry and bed in the morning
yes uh tell me about a day there is no
day there's no of
course time you are um you're traveling
half the time you're dealing with
bilateral relations you're dealing with
the big problems in the uh in the world
and uh when you're in Canada you're
disproportionate doing writing stuff
doing your house Duty that you've missed
in the other house half the time of your
way uh welcoming foreign visitors uh
when you're abroad you're dealing with
like whether it's the Syria problem the
the libia problem the uh Commonwealth
problem so it's uh there's just no day
that's the same what's your um biggest
or maybe one regret that you have uh
from your four years as foreign minister
you know I look back and there's always
things you I wish we could have done
more here I wish we could have done more
uh there um uh but you're always going
to have you know you've only got 24
hours in a day you able to do uh
everything you wanted one of the things
I was got on to my second half of my
time of forign Affairs is how can we
exploit social media uh and the internet
to promote political freedoms uh we're
doing we have a big project we're doing
with the monk School in Iran uh which is
really exciting giving it a democratic
space for people to participate in so
it's uh it's uh I got on to that sort of
in the second half of my time when we
were walking over here um you had some
very nice things to say about
Jean um I wasn't necessarily surprised
but I was just I was I found myself
nodding uh because he did a lot of great
things for Canada as prime minister and
you seem to Echo those views I think
politics is the only business where you
say nice things about people behind
their
backs um I don't agree with a lot of
what John CR did but I think overall he
was a good prime minister uh he tackled
some uh tackling the the huge fiscal
mess the country faced uh was a pretty
big accomplishment and I think everyone
looked at the time that was in Paul
Martin's success and I think more and
more people now look at uh the
leadership had to come from uh from the
top one thing that I enjoy reading every
so often is rankings of prime ministers
you know you see these things published
Michael Bliss has a ranking um who do
you think are some of Canada's greatest
Prime
Ministers and of course we'll exclude
the current occupant just uh to avoid
the conflict there may present um I
think you think of those people who
fought big battles are those people who
had great
accomplishment um I mean obviously
McDonald was huge in terms of the
formation of the country you look at the
consequence that lauia had on promoting
the concept of free trade on bringing
the West in the country
huge
um is very conse quential prime
minister in terms of tax reform in terms
of free trade in terms of you know
Canada's role in the world whether
um you know in the Commonwealth to fight
against
apartheid um things like that pretty
consequential oh just one over here I'll
come back to you in a moment
yes but also Service Officer
department just the issue of question to
you related
to formulation development
forence that Center has shifted during
your time office the center where the
foreign policy is formulated has shifted
from Sussex 125 suex Department of
Affairs located to
was that choice of that simply personal
style of leadership I that's not unique
to foreign policy I think uh you've seen
that um over the certainly in my
lifetime over the last 45 years uh a
huge growth in the size not just of the
pmo but in the size of the privy Council
Office I mean the number of people they
have working on foreign defense and
security policy at the privy Council
Office is huge and uh I often ask
political actors when they live would
leave my office to go and work in the
pmo or a public servant who would leave
the department of Foreign Affairs to go
work at PCO which moment did they know
at all was it the the moment that they
got the halfway point between the two
buildings or was it when they went
through the archway uh in the L block um
so uh I uh from time to times I'd have
problems with that do do you feel that
perhaps and it's just as bad or worse at
the bureaucratic level by the way than
it is at the political level I I
remember I was at a briefing on a
particular issue in my first month or
two on the job and I said well okay well
what does our ambassador said you know
the woman who's on the ground in that
country leading our mission and in
charge of our relationship with that
country oh they hadn't thought to ask
her and that just astounded me um so
it's even we have it at foreign affairs
between Pearson and the field and
there's no excuse for that with all the
the tech you know we don't have to send
cables anymore we can get live on
uh you know you can get live video
connections and have literally the
Ambassador sit at the table and and and
too often they they don't do that they
think they know all the best in the
Pearson building when trust me the the
person who probably be better able to
tell you what's going on on the ground
in Cairo is our ambassador who's sitting
uh on the ground there uh you know the
same would be the case in keev the same
would be the case in Abuja or I me you
name it U so it's just as bad I think
it's just as even bad even among the
official appear Pi in my experience and
you know at the end of the day uh we
live in a democracy at the end of the
day elected officials make decisions I
think that's a good thing not a bad
thing um question on remaining on the
domestic politics um what do you make of
the Quebec question um I think as a as a
foreigner studying in Montreal I think
quite a few of us were quite surprised
to see how much it still was because the
perception from abroad is very much that
you know after that whole Independence
um census it quied down and that now
it's very much integrated um and I think
there is a sense in Quebec and certain
parts of Quebec a very deep sense of or
yearning for for more
Independence um and of a reluctance to
communicate or integrate with the rest
of Canada and it sometimes even goes to
the level of a hatred towards English
speaking Canadians um and I also see a
bit of an indifference uh coming from
the English speaking population for whom
this is not necessarily an issue so I
don't personally have an opinion on it
I'm just curious as to whether you think
that in it will become more and more
integrated in the future and whether
these issues will kind of Qui down I'm
not predicting that Quebec is going to
become more integrated in Canada I can
say that uh support for separation is
lowest in my lifetime in every public
opinion poll I mean Philip quard who one
of the best is the best Premier in
Canada you
know really crushed the PQ in the last
election the block um you know a
dissolution was in two
seats I think few predict you know they
have a chance of picking up more than a
handful if that so I think uh the
support for separation or sovereignty is
is probably its lowest I do worry about
is the attachment to Canada the average
quebecer isn't what I'd like to see it
but we don't have these
uh you know heated battles with Quebec
anymore um even frankly when P marwah
was in government I was told how how
terrible it was going to be and we're
going to be War every day and actually
the relationship at least from a foreign
perspective was
quite professional like I worked well
with her minister of international
issues I worked well with her personally
um obviously I much prefer shereé or
quard as uh as Premier but uh I think by
and large it's much better than it was
um uh
uh prime minister
cretan U was also on the front lines in
the 82 question so I think he probably
got their blood boiling a little bit
more than than other leaders either
Martin or or Harper for
example let me ask you a question about
the Senate of Canada what do you make of
what's happened to the Senate and what
could be its future I'm I'm one who
either needs a major reform or it should
be abolished it's
just people so these senators are not
accountable well that's the whole was
all designed so they wouldn't be
accountable you know when you have a job
for life it's uh you know you never have
to knock on another door or you know
meet a constituent it's
uh no the the strange is we'd be the
only you know big country in the world
without with a un unic Camal system so I
don't know what the answer is but I mean
I think one of the things you do every
day when you get up is you want to move
the ball forward you want to be able to
accomplish something when it comes to
Senate reform I think you're just sort
of taking your head and pounding it
against a brick
wall U because it's a it's a challenge
to fix and it can't be fixed alone all
right there'll be other things that have
to come with it if you ever have
negotiations among all the premier and
and again you just you got 24 hours in
the day say why haven't you addressed
this problem well you know maybe you
tried and it just you looked at your
watch you say I want to move you if I
can't move this ball forward even though
it's an important ball I'm going to get
up every day and push the balls forward
that I that are where I can get
somewhere let me go back to Israel
because I wanted to ask you about Israel
has the relationship between Canada and
Israel evolved over the past 15 years
there's a sense that as you've said
there is a very strong relationship
between Canada and Israel I don't think
people were saying this uh under the
previous government and if that's true
then what explains the new relationship
I just think
we're strong supporters of the state of
Israel it's the only liberal democracy
in the region um I think terrorism is a
great struggle of Our Generation and far
too often Israel's Israelis and Jews
around the world are on the front lines
of that struggle and that's why we
become a strong and vocal supporter of
of the state of Israel as a Jewish State
um it's become a political consensus in
Canada um Trudeau is campaigning saying
that there's no light between him and
the government on foreign policy with
respect to Israel and Tom mare has been
very very uh uh very supportive of the
government's you know position I didn't
get I don't think I got a single
question in question period in four
years but our positions it's become a
virtually consensus and you'll see the
odd NDP will go off on a tangent but
that's about it m can you be seen as an
honest broker can Canada be Hest broker
we're not an honest broker not at all
we're not a refu we're not a referee in
the world that's that's the traditional
Canadian foreign policy in World War I
and World War II we were in on day one
uh we didn't try to you know to uh you
know we have strong values and we work
with like-minded uh people and I think
there was a a construct of in the late
50s and 60s uh and 70s of this is Canada
you know we're peacekeepers when we came
to power we were ranking 31 in the world
for the number of peacekeepers so I mean
the previous government got out of the
peacekeeping business um that's no
change for this government um so um but
it hasn't prevented us I I had an
excellent relationship I I had an
excellent relationship with President
abas Palestinian foreign minister came
totawa Stood Beside Me in front of the
media called me his friend we have great
relations in the Arab world arguably
better today than they've ever
been yes one more over here and then om
follow on sitation Sy refugees in
particular the sitation of refugees you
think Canada can do more no you said
that Canada could do more in your in
your mind what could we do I I think we
can balance off security interest uh
with um with uh humanitarian capacity I
think Canadians want their government to
be want as a people we want to be
generous um and do our share whether we
take 10,000 or 100,000 we've got to stop
the war over there and bring peace that
won't it's not a substitute but that's
not an excuse for not doing anything um
we've we've provided a lot of Financial
Resources uh I think we were either
fifth or sixth in terms of in terms of
you know not just committed support but
delivering support uh particularly the
in in Jordan where the government there
has just been overwhelmed by the scale
of it um I see um you know I mean
obviously we don't want people die in
these rafts going from Turkey to Greece
uh so we want obviously Stop Those flows
um but I think yeah I think Canada can
can do it share and I think you we want
to be a compassionate people and we um
we've done a lot of uh in the region
bring uh persecuted religious minorities
from Iraq gays from Iran I look at what
Canada did with the um uh the Vietnamese
Bo people I mean you know it was a
compassionate thing to do with the time
but it's actually been good for the
country because they're great you know
they've been great citizens um I think
it's become very political and very
charged in an election
campaign omir we'll give you the last
question but just let me ask one
question first Canada's role in Haiti
could you talk a bit about about that
over the years there seems to be a very
close connection we' made it a huge
political priority not just for
development assistance but in terms of
political relations um terms of trade um
it's just the the the challenges that
country faces in terms
of I mean strangely as a conservative
the biggest Chan I got is just a
functioning bureaucracy things like a
land title system things like just the
basic things to you know to making
electricity grid work they've lacked um
they've also had huge political problems
with Congress uh playing a very
unconstructive role with uh the
president the infighting has been
terrible I thought prime minister
Lon um was a decent guy uh beginning to
accomplish things and he was turfed out
uh I don't know whether it was the
president or Congress or both but that's
disappointing uh it's challenging and
we've like I said I think it's our
either our first or second depending on
the year source of De of development
assistance um uh but the challenges that
country fac are just so incredible and
uh you know it's
uh their elected representatives as a as
as a group have failed the country in my
uh in my judgment I'm not pointing
fingers in any one
individual um but uh President Clinton
is the UN special representative I think
he's done a had a done a decent job but
it's just the problems are of such great
magnitude well mayor does Canada still
support a two-state solution in the
Middle East so so what did you do when
you were in office to help bring
diplomacy back um we strongly support a
two-state solution I think uh the only
way that's going to become come about is
if the two parties themselves sit down
and make meaningful
compromises um I've had long discussions
uh with BB I've had long discussions
with President obas uh about this I mean
there's a reason why this is the most
intractable problem in the world uh
um I think if the parties themselves
continue to to take the same approach to
things they're likely not to meet with
success I think the
biggest thing in the interim before an
agreement is reached is the PA has got
to have the capacity to
govern um we've made uh great
development assistance Investments there
particular on the area of security we
work with the United States provide a
lot of money for cour houses for
training of the security officers and
the American and Canadian generals who
work on this give give uh the PA pretty
good marks uh for the capacity that they
built they still got a huge way to go
but they they've come a long way um
we've done a lot investments in the last
two years on economic development
because I think until people have food
in their you know food on their plate
and and a job the atmosphere for peace
isn't going to be as strong as it needs
to be that supplements a peace Pro
process to doesn't um it doesn't uh
replace
it I think a lot of politicians have
been burned um you know ahud Barack is a
friend of mine I mean he virtually
offered the the farm at Camp David in
December 2000 and he asked her if i'
still said
no um I look at bib he appointed Zippy
Livy to be his chief negotiator when he
formed his second government uh third
government um she's a dove she's someone
who the Palestinians like and a admire
and respect and the president abas
appointed s
barcat he's an
the Palestinian leadership
themselves will tell you that um and I
don't know how you're going to make
peace with someone who's so angry and so
bitter um uh this is not the big issue
in the Middle East that Canadians and
people in the west think it is um in
Israel this was barely an issue in their
elections in the Arab world it rarely
comes up uh this to my
discussions um what you need is you need
two strong leaders who are going to be
prepared to make meaningful concessions
that will hurt them and bite them at
home and I just don't think we've seen
that and you see one side when they're
more ready to do it the other side isn't
um Strangely I think President Clinton's
framework was a pretty good one in Camp
David That's the basis of an agreement I
think what'll come down to
um some people more sympath IC to the
Palestinian K side say that yaser arfad
if he had gone home with the December
2000 agreement he would have been
assassinated um well I think we need
leaders who are going to take uh uh you
know bold moves you know prime minister
rabine made a big move for
peace you know by signing the Gordon
bringing the establishment of PA up
president Sadat make it a remarkable
remarkable man of Peace he paid a price
as well um this is what we need we need
great leaders and
uh the the dynamic there isn't good I
mean they constantly each other you know
Israeli expansion expanding
settlements um the incitement that comes
directly from the PA is terrible and it
uh the thing that disappoints me most is
when you see young Palestinians growing
up with a hatred of of of
Israelis uh in their in their curricula
the school textbooks uh surely that's
something we can agree with I had i' got
conversations with President abas about
this on incitement what could we do um
unfortunately didn't really uh really
get anywhere they need strong leadership
in the pa um prime minister Salam fiad
is a great leader um fantastic guy uh I
think he was the person to provide it
but uh things they made it so difficult
for him they pushed him out I I can
remember John krey calling me and saying
you have a good relationship ship with
fed can you get on the phone and
encourage him not to resign I don't
think anyone would have expected a
Canadian foreign minister let alone such
a pro Israel like me wanting to do that
having the kind of relationship where I
could but it uh I mean there's a reason
why this is the most tractable IR
tractable uh problem in the world and
um
uh I think we've got to stop trying to
think we can impose a solution from
Washington it's it's going to have to
come from their two
hearts um
and the one of the more disappointing
things I mean I'm disappointed when they
expand settlements I think it's not just
expansion but it sends a
message that there's no future but when
President abass was asked um you know
the refugee camp in Syria Palestinian
refugee camp in Syria which had been
there for what 66 years was coming under
attack from some of the rebels who
didn't share a pluralist vision
president abas Wasing should could would
you would he take some refugees
Palestinian refugees from from Syria to
the West Bank he said absolutely not I
just that was very you know the type
of the type of leadership that's
uh problematic well before we clap and
thank uh John Barrett one last question
what happens on October 19 the last
question well you know I can improvise
what happens on October 19th the
Canadian federal election um the person
with the most seats will form a
govern oh this is a very um a very
strange one I mean Trudeau came in with
such low
expectations um but he's campaigned well
he mare who I quite like I think is a
smart guy um he's almost been he's
campaigning to the right of the Liberals
the Liberals have gone to the left and
the NDP I think is the cerist
party um he's been very risk averse he's
trying to like you
know deal with any of the traditional
problems that traditional NDP parties
have but he's been too risk averse and I
think it's hurt
him um Trudeau has taken more risks uh
like saying he's want a deficit that's a
that's really challenging the
fundamental consensus of Canadian
politics for a while for at least a
generation um
uh I mean I think obviously Harper's
running on more of the same I his base
is just Rock Solid I mean he's within
the margin of erir on the same poll the
entire
election um we'll see I would not be
surprised uh you know I mean we saw two
elections uh one in British Columbia
with Christy Clark getting elected and
one when Allison Redford was elected and
no one thought there was a hope in Hell
of either them getting elected like at
8:00 when the polls closed and they both
were majority governments and I'm
predict not predicting a majority
government but um there's still two
weeks to go a lot can happen uh chudo
had a big rally last night it looked
like a winner um the TPP has been thrown
in this morning this could Galvanize uh
the NDP and mare it could be a real
Spike for the conservatives I mean who
knows I mean it's uh it's I the good
news is is that we have a competitive
election and that's a good thing I mean
you know it's it's a vibrant
democracy um it's it's funny cuz no one
predicted that it would be going in this
direction at least two weeks out so
we'll see what uh uh we'll see what
happens I am just astounded that you
know after 10 years my part's still in
the hunt you know cuz we you know we're
so you know we're so out of the game for
you know three elections we weren't even
you know credible Alternatives let alone
being within the margin of error of
winning um so that's an incredible thing
um we didn't have
an alternative government in this
country for more than 10 years I think
that's very unhealthy for any uh
democracy so at least we've made it
healthier well thank you so much John
Barrett for your time today it's been
lovely to have you
[Applause]
[Music]
here